>> Kelly: I WANT TO
SCORES! LOOKING TO
GET THAT PUCK TO THE NET AND A
GREAT JOB BYDING IT ACROSS,
PICKED OFF.
LUNDELL, CY GOOD
NUMBER TWO
YES, LOOKS TO BE.
AND SO THE PANTHERS
EQUALIZER, MARCHMENT THEETING O,
WEEGAR, I BELIEVE, AND
HARD-WORKING SHIFT FROM
THE FLAMES AND MANGIAPANE,
REBOUND.TO
THE NET.
[ Laughter ]
F
PRESSURE ON
LUCIC, TRYING TO GET THERE.TILLS
T
JUST THE SCORELINE, KELLY, IN
THE POWER PLAY.
BARKOV,IDA, CALGARY ABLE TO GET
FRESH LEGS OFFY GAUDREAU WOULD Y
BACKLUND AND FOUR FLAMES OUT TO
R
THERE.
SUDDENLY IT IS A CALGARAR
IT IS HANIFIN,HE CORNER, GUDAS,
PUCK TO GUDBRANSON, QUICK SHOT,
DEFLECTED IN
AND IN FRONT, REBOUND, THEY
SCORE AND BENNETTNT, MARCHMENT D
INTO THE POWER PLAY AND THE
FLAMES NOW ARE BAC THE
FRONT AND THERE IS SEAN MONAHAN,
IN THE HIGH SLOT, AND NOW IT
IS JOHNNY GAUDREAU ON A
THERE COULD HAVE BEEN A PENALTY,
S
TKACHUK, THREE FEET, IT.
LOMB FLORIDA.
THAT WAS VERHAEGHE, BADFORSLINGS
WORKING IT